JERRY MARCH: Hi, everybody.
Thank you for coming.
My name is Jerry March.
I am the chief operating officer
and a partner at KenKen Puzzle
Company.
And actually, before I
start, I just wanted to know,
how many of you folks
know what KenKen is?
OK.
So most of you do.
That's great.
Just a little background.
You know, KenKen is a
logic and math puzzle
that was brought to the United
States a number of years ago,
but was originally
developed in Japan.
We're currently in over
150 newspapers worldwide.
We have hundreds of
thousands of puzzles
played every day on
our website, on our iOS
and our Android apps.
And it's really the
fastest-growing puzzle
since Sudoku.
However, as we like to say,
it's really Sudoku on steroids.
It's a much deeper, and as far
as we're concerned, a much more
fun and addicting puzzle.
And it's done by
adults worldwide.
But KenKen was brought
the United States
a number of years ago by
my partner, Bob Fuhrer,
but it was invented in
a Japanese classroom
by our guest today,
Tatsuya Miyamoto.
Mr. Miyamoto has a
very unique style
of teaching, which he
calls the art of teaching
without teaching.
And he used KenKen and other
similar logic types of puzzles
to teach children and to
have them achieve in math,
to teach them reasoning,
creativity, perseverance,
and develop their
self-confidence.
But the way he did
it was very unusual.
And rather than
me go into it, I'd
rather him explain
to you how he used
KenKen and his other puzzles and
how he developed his teaching
method.
So rather than
listen to me speak,
I will introduce Mr. Miyamoto.
And actually, before
I do, I forgot,
I was asked by the powers that
be for you to all make sure
that you turn off your personal
embarrassment devices, whatever
types of devices you have, to
make sure it doesn't go off
in the middle.
So without further ado,
here is Tatsuya Miyamoto.
[APPLAUSE]
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: Hi, everybody.
Why must we learn and study?
For what?
It's for happy life.
Happy life-- what is it?
Entering a high-level
university?
Working with a good
company like Google
and getting a high
salary, like you?
Is it always a happy life?
I don't think so.
Happy life is a life that
you live who you truly are.
Nobody can teach you about that.
You have to find it by yourself.
And self-knowledge and
experiences are necessary.
And you have to think with
your own brain, long and deep.
I run a mathematics class
for primary school students
since 1993.
My math class is unique.
I am a teacher, but I
don't like teaching.
In fact, I don't teach.
The art of teaching
without teaching is my way.
I had thought, how can
I make students smart?
Do you think that
students become smart
after a careful explanation?
No, not at all.
If this is true, my
job is a piece of cake.
After a careful
explanation, students
have an illusion that
they can understand.
But they cannot solve the
problem by themselves.
When I was young, I liked to
teach and thought too much.
My poor students could not
think with their own brains.
It's my mistake and sin.
I changed my mind.
Then, how can I
make students smart?
I found the answer at last.
The essence of
learning mathematics
is to keep thinking.
It doesn't matter whether
you can solve or not.
you can understand or not.
Do not want the answer.
Just enjoy trial and error.
Then, someday, the correct
answer will come up to you.
Reason three, I
have many chances
to drink with my
former students.
Of course, they're
over 21 years old.
All of my former students I
reunite with spend happy life.
They enjoy challenges in life
as they enjoyed trial and error
in my math lesson
in their childhoods.
It makes me happy, because
they're living evidences
that Miyamoto's method, the art
of teaching without teaching,
is really working.
By the way, do you know KenKen?
KenKen is a math puzzle.
It looks like this.
You may see it in "New
York Times" or "LA Times."
KenKen is now over 150
newspapers or magazines
all over the world.
And I am the inventor of KenKen.
Now I'll tell you my
KenKen invention story.
First two years after
I founded my class,
I had only math lessons
for fourth grade
to sixth grade of
primary school students.
Do you know that there are
four kinds of math problems,
easy and fun, easy and no fun,
difficult and fun, difficult
and no fun?
I make only
interesting problems.
I believe that only
interesting problems
can make students smart.
They can catch students' hearts
easily and never release.
I had an interesting experience
related to that belief.
Do you remember we
had a heavy earthquake
in Japan, March 11 in 2011?
It was Friday afternoon.
I was walking on my way to home.
The ground began
to move suddenly.
It was the biggest earthquake
I've ever experienced.
And I had lessons on the
next day and two days later.
Transportation network was
not recovered completely,
but surprisingly,
most of the students
came to attend classes.
A lot of aftershock
occurred during lessons.
I felt clearly,
and I was scared.
But no student laid their head.
They didn't even
recognize aftershocks,
because they were devoted into
my program very, very deep.
I was so surprised and
impressed-- how great.
All of my students
are not so smart,
because I don't select students.
I accept my students
first come, first
served basis without an exam.
So this miracle is
something caused
by the force of my problems.
Almost all math problems for
fourth grade to sixth grade
were made by me in
the first two years.
I wanted to start something new.
Some parents who
had third graders
asked me, please set up a
class for third graders.
I considered it for one week.
I didn't want to give
them math problems.
Rather, I wanted to
give them material which
they enjoyed trial and error.
And I searched good materials
for thinking, and I found it.
It's a puzzle.
I started puzzle class
for third graders in 1995.
They were absorbed in
puzzles day by day.
They became to think
longer and deeper.
I made many kinds of
puzzles almost every day,
but they were not enough.
I needed puzzles that
required all four operations,
and I invented KenKen in 2003.
First, KenKen was a four-by-four
grid size, as is shown, only.
And I created KenKen with
addition only, four-by-four
to nine-by-nine grid size.
Then I created KenKen with
a variety of combinations
of operations, such as addition
and subtraction, multiplication
only, multiplication and
division, and all four
operations with symbols.
I continued to make
KenKen one after another.
Finally, I deleted
math operations,
which added an additional
challenge that made
students think even harder.
All trials were successful.
At last, one KenKen
was completed.
I did it.
I couldn't stop
screaming and dancing.
I did it.
Like Archimedes, I have
made many kinds of puzzles.
KenKen is one of them, but
KenKen is a special one.
KenKen could make my
students strive dramatically.
They never give up.
They never compromise.
My teaching method, the art
of teaching without teaching,
where students have to
struggle to figure out answers
by themselves, has
made them successful in
many different areas in life.
They become successful medical
doctors, bankers, scientists,
teachers, farmers, and artists.
One of them even
became a ballerina
in a famous ballet
theater in Europe.
Recently, I went to drink
with my former student who is
the first generation of KenKen.
He goes to the best
medical school in Japan.
He looked focused and determined
forward the goal of his life.
To me, KenKen clearly
supports my students
to have happy lives, so I'm
looking forward to drink
with more KenKen generations.
Not only to my
students, but KenKen
also gives me many benefits.
KenKen made me famous.
KenKen made me rich.
Now I have classes in
Manhattan and Tokyo.
I live in Manhattan
eight months and live
in Tokyo four months in a year.
It's exciting and interesting.
Before I came to
Manhattan, I was already
having a happy life
in Tokyo, so I didn't
need to do something new.
But two experiences changed
my thoughts in 2013.
The first experience
began from one email.
I previously was interested
in only my classroom, and only
my students.
I received an email
from a math teacher
in Paris American
school, Melissa.
She said, we are going to
Japan with 18 the students
next April.
Can we visit to your
classroom with my students?
I'd like you to give a
lesson to my students.
I know your classroom
is near Tokyo Station.
I was surprised that she knew
about me and my philosophy,
very much.
I thought about it for one week,
because I cannot speak English
very well.
It's my serious weak
point, even now.
But I decided to accept them.
I believed it must be
a beautiful experience
for me and for them.
Melissa and I exchanged
emails quite often.
A few months later, three
teachers and 18 students
came to Tokyo.
The students were
14 to 16 years old.
As a first stage, I put 30
kinds of my books on the table.
And I told them,
I'll give you a book.
Pick one.
But be careful, because you
will try to solve it later.
Including the three teachers,
everyone took a book
and went back to their seat.
Then I said, I'll
give you 50 minutes.
Do as you like.
Everybody began to solve.
Nobody gave up.
Melissa said to me,
it's really amazing
to see my students continue
thinking such a long time.
I answered, it's the
power of my books.
Interesting problems can
catch students' heart easy
and never release.
The students of Paris wanted
to meet Japanese students,
so I sent an email to my
former student in [INAUDIBLE],
and 17 students joined
the event that day.
The second stage was a puzzle
contest with my new puzzle
that no one had
ever seen before.
Three talented former students
had a fierce dead heat,
and one of them
became world champion.
It was really exciting.
The third stage was an
exchange meeting of one to one.
The students at Paris talked
slowly in the beginning,
but a few minutes
later, they began
to talk with normal speed.
I thought my former students
could not understand,
but I let them [INAUDIBLE].
After that, most of my former
students who joined the event
went to study abroad.
The final stage was karaoke.
We moved to a karaoke box, and
we sang only one song, "You've
Got a Friend" by Carole King.
Do you know that?
(SINGING) When you're
down and troubled
and you need some loving
care, and nothing, nothing
is going right--
That song.
I love that song very
much, but nobody knew it.
So I sent an email, the
YouTube URL of the song,
and asked them, practice
more than 100 times.
We will sing this song
at the end of the event,
and we could sing
aloud, together.
After that, I sent off the
Paris team at the station.
It was one of the most
beautiful days in my life.
It was also the day
I had the first time
interested in students
other than my own.
Five days later, Melissa
gave me a heartwarming email.
She said it was the most
memorable day, like a dream,
visiting Japan this time.
I appreciate you and all staff
from the bottom of my heart.
After reading this
email, I thought,
all students in American
schools come to Japan.
I will entertain you.
This was an eye-opening
experience to me.
Here is a group of
fashionable students
who seemed completely
uninterested in math,
loved and benefited
from my puzzles.
And I wondered whether
or not the same
would hold true
in another country
where students have
less opportunity.
I had the chance to visit
a primary school in Chiang
Rai, Thailand, a month after
Melissa and her students
came to see me.
I had a plan to teach
how to solve KenKen
and how to make KenKen.
I would tell them, if you can
make more than 100 KenKen,
I will bring them to
the publishing company
to publish the book.
All the royalties of the book
will be donated to your school.
So I went to Thailand, and
I had 90-minute lessons
to fifth graders
and sixth graders.
Before the trip, I was warned,
they can not even calculate,
so I was very nervous.
But it was not true.
They enjoyed KenKen,
just like my students.
Some of them were much
smarter than I expected.
They could solve KenKen,
and they could make KenKen.
I thought that, the schools
all over the world, call me.
I will go to entertain you.
These two experiences changed
my thoughts dramatically.
I wanted to have lessons with
students in foreign countries.
I was waiting and waiting,
but nothing happened.
I needed to grow myself,
and I needed a challenge.
What should I do next?
Where should I go?
Next to the center of
Japan, near Tokyo Station,
one idea came to me.
It's Manhattan, New York,
near Grand Central Station.
I decided to move my classroom
from Tokyo to Manhattan.
Only five months later,
this event happened.
The biggest benefit
from KenKen was
the-- the biggest
benefit from KenKen
was that KenKen brought
me to New York City.
I moved to New York in February
10, 2015, with a green card.
[CLAPPING]
Thank you very
much-- category E11.
Before that, I had an interview
in the United States embassy
in Tokyo.
The counselor says to me,
your visa is wonderful.
I couldn't understand at all.
I checked up category
E11 on the internet.
The Immigration
Department said, it's
for individuals in
extraordinary abilities
in the arts, science, education,
business, or authority.
Unbelievable-- it's
because of KenKen.
I'm an ordinary man.
I don't have any talent.
Thank you, KenKen.
KenKen was originally
handmade by me,
but the mass market, a
KenKen-generating program
was required.
KenKen Puzzle Company
contracted with a pioneer
in computer chess development
and long-time president
of the Computer
Games Association.
AI expert Dr. David Levy
interviewed me extensively
and applied this
knowledge in engineering
to help design the algorithm
that is known as "Kenerator."
The Kenerator verified
that there is only one
solution in each puzzle.
Sometimes solvers
contact us believing they
have found a flaw in a puzzle.
But up to now, no puzzle
generated by Kenerator
has ever been found to have an
error or alternative solution.
I feel KenKen has
unlimited possibilities.
It's a dream of mine to
create an online head-to-head
competition platform
where students
from Thailand or Paris
or the United States
can create their own KenKen,
solve each other's KenKen,
and compete in the way where
language isn't a barrier.
Then, KenKen will be a true
international learning tool.
Now I'll show you
how to make KenKen.
Before that, let's go
over the rules of KenKen.
This is four by
four, addition only.
You can use 1, 2, 3, 4.
Every row, every column
has 1, 2, 3, 4 once.
Do not repeat the same
number on the same line.
OK?
You can use 1, 2, 3, 4.
And the small numbers
mean some of the numbers
in the heavy line.
Two numbers make 7.
What are these two numbers?
Only one combination.
AUDIENCE: 4, 3.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 4, 3.
4, 3.
4, 3 or 3, 4.
Next, two numbers make 6.
What are these two numbers?
2, 4.
3 and 3 is against the rules.
2, 4 or 4, 2.
Anyway, what is this?
AUDIENCE: 3.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 3 and?
AUDIENCE: 4.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: Good.
3, 2, 4 or 3, 4, 2.
Anyway, what is this?
AUDIENCE: 1.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 1.
Two numbers make 3.
What is this?
AUDIENCE: 1, 2.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: Great.
Here is 7.
Here is 4.
What is this?
AUDIENCE: 3.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 3 and?
AUDIENCE: 4.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 4.
2, 4, 4, 2-- here is 4.
Then, what is this?
AUDIENCE: 2.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 2 and?
AUDIENCE: 4.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 4.
4, 3, 2, then 1.
Two numbers make 3.
AUDIENCE: 2.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 2.
4, 1, 2-- then?
AUDIENCE: 3.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 3.
Two numbers make 4.
Then?
1.
Two numbers make 7.
Here is 4.
What is this?
AUDIENCE: 3.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 3 and?
AUDIENCE: 4.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 4.
4, 1, 3-- then?
AUDIENCE: 2.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 2.
AUDIENCE: 1.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: Perfect.
Well done, but it's not the end.
Let's check the answer.
Every row, every column
has 1, 2, 3, 4 once.
3 plus 4 equals 7, 1 plus 2, 3,
3, 1, 4, 1, 2, 3, 4, 2, 6, 3,
4, 7, 1, 2, 3, 3, 4.
Perfect.
Next, I'm going to show
you how to make KenKen.
I usually make KenKen
from the answer.
I'm going to make
the first block here.
Sum of 1, 2, 1 equals 4.
Second block here.
Sum of 1, 2, 3.
Then, 6.
Next, 4 plus 3 equals 7.
Next, 3 plus 4 equals 7.
4 plus 2 equals 6.
1 plus 2 equals 3.
3 plus 4 equals 7.
It's a KenKen problem
and its answer.
I deleted the answer numbers.
I will delete the
answer numbers.
Then, one KenKen baby
has just been born.
My baby, how cute you are.
Let's solve it.
Three numbers make 6.
What are the three numbers?
AUDIENCE: 1, 2, 3.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 1, 2, 3.
1, 2, 3.
Anyway, what is this?
AUDIENCE: 4.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 4, 3.
Three numbers make 4,
only one combination, 1--
AUDIENCE: 2.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 2--
AUDIENCE: 1.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: That's right.
Next, two numbers make 3.
Here is one.
What is this?
AUDIENCE: 2.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 2 and?
AUDIENCE: 1.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 1.
1, 2-- then?
AUDIENCE: 3.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 3.
Here is 1.
What is this?
2, 1.
3, 2, 1-- then?
AUDIENCE: 4.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 4 and?
AUDIENCE: 2.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 2.
1, 4, 2-- then?
AUDIENCE: 3.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 3, 4--
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 3.
Perfect.
Let's check the problem
by KenKen solver.
[INAUDIBLE] Every KenKen
has only one solution.
If it has more than two
solutions, it's failed.
Let's check this problem.
This solver is only for me.
Three numbers make 6.
Two numbers make 7.
Three numbers make 4.
Two numbers make 6.
Two numbers make 3.
Two numbers make 7.
Let's check the answer.
Only one solution-- perfect.
Is there anybody who
wants to make a KenKen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
these markers?
That's OK.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: OK, cool So I like
to start with ones that there's
only one solution.
So I might box off
this and make a 9.
And then I might
make-- oh, thank you.
Sorry.
OK-- 8.
And then I would probably
make this, here, a 5.
And then I'd probably
make this an 8.
Sorry.
And then, make that a 7.
And then I'd probably
make this a 5.
And then, I'd probably make
this a freebie, with just a 3.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO:
One moment, please.
Does your KenKen have
only one solution?
Do you guarantee?
AUDIENCE: I'll have
to see in a second.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 3, 4, 3.
AUDIENCE: That's a freebie.
Is it OK?
Or should I make it--
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: Ah, only one.
Hai, hai, hai.
Only one 3.
3.
[INAUDIBLE]
5.
AUDIENCE: Oh, wait,
I think it's 5.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: There you go.
[INAUDIBLE] The 3 there-- 7.
7 and?
AUDIENCE: Oh, 8?
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: 8.
8.
Let's check the answer.
Congratulations.
Well done.
[INAUDIBLE]
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Should I take it off?
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: Mm-hmm.
There are three ways
of enjoying KenKen,
to solve, to make, and
to serve to somebody.
The most important thing
is to continue thinking,
long and deep.
The toughest rival is not
the person next to you,
it's yourself yesterday.
Sometimes people ask for
my autograph in my book.
I always write this, "Renew
your best record day by day."
I believe math is a puzzle.
A puzzle is fun.
Then, math is fun.
It's the best entertainment
to progress yourself.
Let's learn and study.
Let's enjoy trial and
error with your own brain
for your happy life.
Good luck.
Thank you for listening.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: What does
the name "KenKen" mean?
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO:
"Ken" means wisdom.
"KenKen" is wisdom squared.
This kanji called Ken, it is
used as a boy's name-- Kenta,
Kenji, Kenjiro-- wisdom.
And here is a small 2.
It's squared.
SPEAKER: Is there anybody else?
AUDIENCE: Thank
you for your talk.
Are your classes
available to the public?
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: Public?
SPEAKER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE].
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO:
Yes, of course.
I have class only on Saturday,
third grade to fifth grade.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Do you teach-- like,
how do you teach the student
to do the KenKen?
According to the examples
you showed during your talk,
it's all like, you can
use logic to just solve
the problem once without trial.
So is there a lot
of-- instruction book
you give kids to solve
your KenKen puzzle,
or it's like, just
explore yourself?
SPEAKER: [SPEAKING JAPANESE].
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: Ah, of course.
In the first lesson, I tell
them the rule, every row,
every column has 1, 2, 3, 4.
Do not repeat the same
number on the same line.
That's all.
Do it.
Do it or go home, as you like.
Up to you.
Learning English and learning
mathematics are very different.
And for the beginner, like
me, the English beginner
has to memorize so many things.
But mathematics, addition,
subtraction, multiplication,
division, that's all.
After that, it's a
problem of combination.
It's not my business, yours.
That's right.
AUDIENCE: Did you teach
your class just doing that
for a whole year?
I mean, there must
have been more.
Did each day, they come
and just get puzzles?
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO: Ah, puzzles
are only for third grade.
Fourth grade and fifth grade
learn mathematics problems.
And now, I run a math
class at the corner
of 39th Street and 6th Avenue.
It's only on Saturday,
so everybody is welcome.
SPEAKER: So this is
the end of his speech.
And thank you so much
for participating today.
And if you have
any more questions,
please feel free to
ask him a question.
So thank you so much
for participating.
Thank you.
TETSUYA MIYAMOTO:
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]